thousands of workers are on strike this
morning across the u.s that includes
more than 10 thousand employees at john
deere plants around 1400 kellogg's
employees have been on strike for nearly
two weeks and 24 000 kaiser permanente
health care workers have authorized a
strike on monday film and tv production
across the country could shut down in a
work stoppage involving 60 000 crew
members they're demanding safer working
conditions jonathan bigliotti has more
currently i work
sometimes 80 hours a week you say 80
hours a week so casually yeah
amy thurlow is a writer's assistant in
hollywood a job that makes just over
state minimum wage she's also a member
of the international alliance of
theatrical stage employees or ayatsi
a union with around 60 000 of some of
the most essential workers in
entertainment like camera operators and
set designers who could all strike on
monday we're talking about people who
love their work ayati president matthew
loeb says his members are asking for
better pay and quality of life like a
guarantee of 10 hours between shifts a
person might go to work in the morning
and not get a meal for nine or 10 hours
or a break during the day
ayatsi is not the only union taking
action more than 10 thousand united auto
workers at john deere plants are
striking for the first time in 35 years
walking away from a contract that would
have provided up to a six percent raise
which workers said was not enough as
company earnings are expected to hit
record highs
really doing what we needed to do
standing up for ourselves with more than
10 million open jobs across the u.s and
much of the country rebounding from the
worst of covet 19 a more assertive labor
force shouldn't come as a surprise says
former labor secretary robert reich at
the end of that crisis
workers begin to say wait a minute maybe
i ought to be doing better you have this
huge surge in pent-up demand at the same
time you've got a shortage of workers
and a lot of workers know
that this is the time if there's ever a
time to flex their muscles for cbs
mornings i'm jonathan vigliotti in los
angeles
now all of the companies involved in
these labor disputes say they are
committed to reaching fair contracts for
all parties and the workers are saying
what we got so far is not fair right
about that